[Music]
[Applause]
you guys you guys welcome back to the
break room Our Daily Show that keeps you
updated on all the nerdy news that you
need to know about coming up today
Avatar passes Infinity War Avatar passes
Infinity War what oh no Shazam gets a
new trailer we're going to talk a lot
about that and we answer all your nerdy
questions but first please let me
introduce my best friend Brandon Barry
oh I didn't know me thank you Jessica
sorry to everyone else at this table
well best friend number two Greg Alba
yeah who let him in the office
I like it a lot you guys are doing so
much and you rock stars now oh too much
too much
I don't know about that
and last but not least the king of our
Castle Eric King Voss oh I wouldn't call
myself King of the castle except it's
one of those countries where the king is
thrown out and has to move to a
different place and is an exile because
that's right
which was there is because there was
like eight viserys you don't look like
withering away you look like the first
episode
[Applause]
I hate all of this you asked for it well
we have Greg on the show with us today
which is very exciting yeah this is the
Greg hour but after this uh we're gonna
Greg and I are gonna run back over to
his place and we're gonna live stream
over in the real rejects
it's a double header hope there's no
traffic or police chase is on the 101
because yeah everyone out there uh it's
a big day on the internet folks we're
breaking the internet
um or at least one tiny Corner Kim who
never heard of her never heard of you
know what I have heard of what headlines
whoa
oh that's a Segway heck of a segue just
bless you for that folks here's our
first headline Avatar way of water
surpasses Infinity War to become number
the number five highest grossing movie
of all time the sequel film is now
sitting at just over 2 billion dollars
worldwide and they got 25.99 out of me
dude because it's expensive to see a
movie out here uh this gives James
Cameron three of the top five highest
grossing movies and he has not made that
many movies when you look at his cattle
what is tight what happens when the
fourth and fifth Avatar come out does
that also include is that what happens
are the top five movies just gonna be
Avatar movies like that's how big this
franchise is now I guess maybe how many
times have you seen her Jessica zero
zero money I win I got my ticket and
then I was like I was in a mood where I
was like I can't sit for three hours and
12 minutes or four hours whatever it was
and then I was like I need to go watch
it and I still just have not but you
know what when you see this movie you
won't be sitting for three hours until
minutes you will be levitating from
traveling you'll be transported to
Pandora I've seen it twice and both
times it actually does not feel like
three hours it really genuinely does not
do it it moves by so I will say after
the movie me pissing into the urinal was
like the scene where the the ships land
on the planet and the fire is just
wiping everything out because I have so
much piss built up in my body from
sitting there for so long how much
dialogue isn't it how much would you say
the percentage of dialogue to action
well bro there's a lot of good in
dialogue in there because
if you see an avatar you know what I'm
talking about I'm so excited because I
know what you're I know what you're
leaning at I know what you're leaning at
and now I'm gonna go see it tonight for
a movie where it mostly takes place
amongst the navi there's a lot of
English beans yeah and I think I think
that that dialogue is better than in the
2009 movie I think the way it begins I
think Jake Sully's uh opening monologue
is pretty beautiful like I think it's
good I think it establishes some
interesting things about the lore of uh
Pandora and it's not as it's not as
cringy I don't think okay I noticed you
said Jake Sully there what's his Avatar
name
does he know you Jason
with an accent accent uh but thankfully
the villain still calls him James only
so we're like oh I know what you're
talking about I think he has a title
right he has the we have a name I think
I I thought that's just like the ranking
yeah it's like kind of the cheap it says
the mythological figure when when they
tackle the the big beast it's a tell us
what you're saying yeah yeah that's like
his title I don't think it's his name
okay that's what they call some people
call him that and that's like a sign of
respect for him sure if you know his
name Colin please but uh until then
we'll oh it's toruk makuto which like
this
the thing he tackles that it had is
derived from that name yeah okay oh okay
okay we'll call him Jake Sully yeah I
see you Jake Sally you gotta watch it
Jess oh my God you're gonna love it
you're gonna love it it's fine it's
definitely worth seeing in the theaters
with the glasses and all that I'm I'm
afraid it's gonna be in theaters for a
minute to be fair but like I'm afraid of
it leaving theaters and me missing it
because I know I will once it leaves
theaters I will not be watching it it's
just funny to see how it's like one of
the top grossing movies now because Pete
there was that conversation that it
might fail yeah that it might not make
two billion dollars
never doubt him never ever down him
folks uh next headline according to box
office Pro Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania is projected to take in
between 96 and 131 million dollars
domestically in its first three days big
gap a lot of money in that Gap folks
yeah uh what do you guys think leaning
closer to 131 or closer to 96. they
break 100. I think it breaks 100. yeah
yeah it's been a minute forever it was
last year but like that's why I'm like
people are probably they're like yes I
know phase five let's start it so let's
go do you know the run time of the movie
uh it's just over two hours it's like
two hours and like eight minutes the
Ant-Man movies have been shorter but
this is the longest of the three but it
is in comparison if we look back at like
phase four right black panther what kind
of forever took in 180 million and it's
opening weekend or first three days Thor
11 Thunder snagged 141 million and
Multiverse event list was the most uh
profitable one last year coming in at
185 million dollar opening weekend yeah
I think people were ready maybe I think
people are ready I think Marvel and
Disney are smart keeping expectations
lower just because the first two Ant-Man
movies didn't do as well as some of
their other releases but I think the
fact that Kang is in this and I think
it's a launch of Marvel phase five I
think word of mouth on this movie's
gonna be pretty good and people are
genuinely very excited for Modoc and I
think that's a another Grabber is of
being like Oh they're gonna go see for
all the new people Scotland modoc's
going to be the big cell yes yeah I
think 40 million
40 billion dollars
puts a lot of asses in seats too people
love Paul people do when he was at the
Brazilian Comic-Con that crowd went ape
[__] for King
it was Paul red Paula just stood up with
The Infinity Gauntlet and the crowd went
wild and they had to pause the interview
I did have a dream last night that admin
failed at the box
and Greg's dreams always come true we've
got to do something about it something
you got like a 65 on Rotten Tomatoes I
never dream about things like that but
yeah maybe it's gonna come different on
my mind apparently did he dream about
any of our deaths cause don't tell me I
don't want to know what's coming
hmm well you probably know this already
because you haven't been able to tear
yourself away from it the new trailer
for Shazam Fury of the Gods came out
today so we took to Twitter to answer
and ask some of your boring questions uh
if you've got questions about the
trailer go ahead and throw them in the
chat uh we'll be looking for questions
um we'll answer any questions you got
throw out questions about Shazam throw
questions about apple pie I don't know
whatever you got uh one of the first
questions we got came from MMA anomaly
or mm anomaly I don't know which one it
is uh is it going to be James Gunn's DCU
Cannon or will it be rebooted I think
they're talking about like Shazam 2 here
is this gonna be like part of is is
Shazam gonna slip into James guns soon
to be revealed DCU Canon or they're
gonna reboot the character of Shazam are
they gonna keep Shazam I think whether
they keep him will depend on the success
of this movie I think everyone at Warner
including James Gunn is hoping that it's
successful my my thinking I think the
smartest way for James Gunn to go I
really had a chance to talk about James
Gunn's plan yet I've been on my
honeymoon and trying to get the Deep
dive going but realistically I think the
smartest move for James Gunn is to
introduce the DC Multiverse as an
elseworld slate uh and maybe not even
use the word Multiverse but just call it
DC else worlds right and that every DC
movie keep the stuff that works uh
reboot the stuff that does it but I
think the fact that you know the Matt
Reeves Robert Patton said Batman did as
well as it did I don't know if I need to
see a different separate Batman in in a
Justice League movie right now but I
love what Robert Pattinson did with the
character I love what Matt Reeves is
doing with that world so that could just
be one corner it's one else world uh the
flash can kind of see the ending of the
previous version of the DC EU it sounds
like they're still pretty that movie's
very important right yeah so all of this
stuff going forward we can't really
answer
exactly what it's going to be but I
don't think James's gun should make his
Universe beholden to any any of the past
I think he should keep he would give
himself a clean slate option to play I
think I mean I I agree with you and I
saw some Twitter thread going around
recently that was sharing some of James
Gunn's thoughts about universes before
he even was announced okay the one
spearheading this and he I feel like
starting off with elsewhere I think
elseworld seems like the logical
conclusion for where we often venture to
go but I feel like he could actually
take Shazam because he hasn't crossed
over into a Justice League movie yet
because he he doesn't like the idea of
having multiple versions right away he
says that creates a lot of problems that
even with Peacemaker people were asking
like is there going to be which Joker
would be cancer he still gets this
question from like people from all over
the world and we understand the
differences but like there's a lot of
people who don't so I think that for
this one I mean this James going to kind
of this is actually a serious question
is he the kind of guy who would be the
one super concerned about how how it
financially does no that's what I yeah
that's what I was thinking I was like I
don't think so I think he thinks about
the storyline and the stories that
create that come out of it and I think
are great which take it as you will I
think a great opportunity is for him to
take Shazam and put it in The Peacemaker
world or just like have those two people
meet and I think he's thinking about his
properties too still of like what can we
push forward what do people already like
how can we take this like comedy and
make it even bigger yeah and I mean
about the previous DC characters from
the Snyder years Shazam feels the most
like James gunnable to me in its current
iteration where it's about a boy trying
to find his place in a family that's you
know not his like born family but a
created family and how they all interact
those are the stories that like James
Gunn like to tell and I think already
like Shazam family uh felt like a movie
that didn't feel like part of Zack
Snyder's Universe it didn't it already
felt separate it did have like the bat
the Ben affle
and then we didn't see Superman's face
yeah but it was implied to be the Henry
Cavill one I my issue with it I agree I
think that how comedic the first shazam
movie was and how comedic this one it
seems to be it just doesn't have the
sense of maturity that James Gunn
approaches his comedy with and by
maturity I'm not saying James Gunn's
jokes are all super mature many of them
are sophomoric but that's part of why we
like it but it's R-rated yeah and and
Shazam the first movie was very much
like kind of a wholesome family comedy
it had some jokes that were a little
dirty but like you'd have to really age
up the the humor and the Shazam movies
for it to fit in with this is All PG-13
I mean it'll be those little DNA's all
over there
Jackson
Pollock was not a PG-13 I think it's
those little moments and also I I mean
not that the DC is doing this but I like
that Marvel's already kind of doing this
where they had like She-Hulk just
gracefully doing things that were like
an adult thing to do and we're slowly
getting into there I think it's slowly
becoming like oh how can we bring
Daredevils toxic
crazy Shoreline into this and the step
by step bring it in so I think
but I think with this one I think like
even the opportunity in Shazam won when
he was buying the liquor and buying
alcohol and trying to date people are
older than him as Shazam taking those
little quirky moments and putting it
still in Peacemaker or Peacemaker coming
there and doing those little quirky
moments where it's still like this is a
child that's an adult and an adult body
and doing child adult things just as
peacemakers I love that the speculation
has become is this going to be The
Peacemaker Universe
I think I did a rogue theory that was
just like why get rid of Shazam when
there are a lot of opportunities to put
them in different places and I don't
think James Gunn does things off of
profit I think he does it out of
Storytelling Jessica you're on fire with
that one let me just say uh you brought
it up Eric and it came oh I don't even
notice uh it came up on Twitter uh 1010
quiet quaterino man I should have tried
these before Tintin quarantrino
quarantino uh sure where would you think
uh the post credit from the first movie
would fit into the sequel so the post
guy for the first Shazam is a headless
Superman walking in now we never saw his
head I thought that was the ending the
postcarded scene was a little uh
it was mind it's something doctor uh
mind something I forget I forgot the
name of the character yeah but yeah I
think it's a Mr mind yeah
second most horrifying scene from
detective Pikachu after of course the
ditto sequence which gives me nightmares
uh yeah Mr mind I yeah I don't know I
mean I think that'll get referenced in
this movie because it's the same
director it's the same characters I
think it'll get referenced uh I don't uh
I I don't think it's gonna be a major
plot point I think it might get
referenced kind of like in a jokey way
where I think treat that like Howard the
Duck was treated at the end of the first
Guardians of the Galaxy he makes a cameo
in the second Guardians of the Galaxy he
showed up to save Earth in the Battle of
Earth which is nice to see but I don't
think he's gonna be a major player I'd
be surprised maybe the movie starts with
the shot at Slug and then a foot comes
down just squishes it and we move on
like in the boys season two three yeah
[Laughter]
I only I immediately once you guys said
it was like oh yeah because I was
thinking about the Superman one too I
was like oh yeah I don't think they're
gonna acknowledge I really I really want
super Henry cavilles who were meant to
be in this movie we all went to Henry
Cavill Superman to be in every move yeah
and then cut to the Rock in his house
just like smashing everything
just being so angry you think he was so
angry James Gunn reaches out and he's
like hey can you do this one scene of
you and your Mansion breaking these
because you have a chance we get Black
Adam in this movie there was a CG
version of Black Adam in the first movie
right that's right you see like the
fight sequence where he killed Atlas or
whatever like do they bring in Black
Adam in this I mean I would imagine that
David F sandberg's version of this movie
it makes sense to have Black Adam Cameo
but I don't know in James Gunn's DC
whatever their plan was for black item
too is off the table now prior to that
Dwayne Johnson was pretty adamant about
it right yeah yeah kids movie watch
that's something that they could do oh
like see the condom footage they're
watching the movie yeah
you know what they should do is take the
shots that were in the trailer of him
like punching the fighter jet down and
just put that on the news and it makes
it okay that we shot that for a reason
they had a news camera there in the sky
that's a freaky folks uh this is what I
got okay from uh Shawnee or at Johnny
underscore Matt I messed it up already
will this be Zachary Levi's last
portrayal of Shazam what are your
thoughts on him possibly they're not
confirmed joining the new DCU I think
he's trying to talk about you can't he
would love it I think he's got a good
chance to get in as Shazam oh yeah I
don't know if he has a good chance I
mean it just seems like everything's on
The Chopping Block right now because
again Clean Slate clean slate and I
think if this movie is successful I
think we're all gonna want it I think
many of us who are you know were fans of
that of that 2019 film uh and like the
take on this character and like this
corner of the world yeah I I think
there's no reason why this can't exist
in world's version I think the only
reason so far of the cancellations we
know of of the of the firings are moving
in other directions or we'll use Capital
another way that we know of it's really
just to to shake off the old era and to
give themselves more options to move
forward and I think there's no reason
why Shazam cannot exist in the new DCU
if it's successful and if people just
like that that corner of the world just
let it exist as an elsewhere that might
Bridge with things like Peacemaker I
just don't think they'll be doing like
more Shazam movies
you know what I mean like I think
they're gonna say this we're gonna have
a new timeline we're gonna follow but
that isn't encompassing the whole else
worlds yeah we're just going to have one
specific timeline we're following and I
feel like Zachary Levi's doing whatever
he can too he is sure all of our social
media the question is are we going to
get another crisis on infinite Earth's
event because technically we already did
through the arrowverse shows on on uh
the CW because you know uh Ezra's
version of The Flash crossed over with
the CW version of it so that was a
crisis event and it did bring in a ton
of people from from the past films from
the Richard Donner Superman era and the
Tim Burton version era of the character
so that was quite one crisis event but
like you could do a true big screen
crisis event that would be really really
exciting that would just take the best
and the most exciting versions from
these elsewhere Henry Cavill and Dwayne
Johnson he could yeah yeah Dwayne
Johnson's promise is still possible
right so possible yeah he as soon as he
unfollowed his own Instagram account of
Black Adam he was like don't bring me
into this ever again what about Shazam
and Joker too what I think yes and I won
100 it's absolutely gonna I'll play it
my firstborn on it uh no I will not
I mean you probably have Matt Reeves the
Batman like that's over I can never see
you know Robert Patton to Batman meeting
like Shazam Zachary Levi
or or like we want to go Robbie's uh or
even any version of Superman would feel
weird in like the Matt Reeves University
to me anyway 100 agree keep it separate
gotta keep it separated uh I I also I
think we talked about this in please
counter if you know
um that we love the Shazam is taking
place in Philly and we were like oh if
it does come into if they do combine it
are we just gonna like acknowledge that
these people are in Philly and these
people are in a made-up world like do
you know what I'm talking about like
there's the multiple cities yeah in the
DC Universe like they have both New York
and Metropolis they have both Boston and
Gotham yeah so we can't really or well I
guess we could we could be like yeah
Gotham still exists and there's
Philadelphia yeah and we're destroying
all these build aliens which Batman got
in trouble for but it's okay yeah yeah
but the destruction of all these bones
right well we'll get to some more of
those questions in a second uh well
first we gotta thank our sponsor today
uh Factor meals pretty good uh uh we
know that like cooking could be like a
pain in the butt and I'll go to the
grocery store chop it up all the food oh
that sounds annoying but you could save
time and energy with factors ready to
eat meals which are delivered straight
to your door folks and they're ready in
just like two minutes pop them in the
microwave beep boop boop you got
yourself dinner Factor has meals that
are keto calorie smart vegan and veggie
they're full of protein and prepared by
chefs and approved by dietitians okay
this is good food for you good
ingredients none of the ingredients you
don't want just like the good healthy
stuff they have 34 chefs prepared
dietitian approved weekly options so
there's always something new to try plus
you can round out your meals and
replenish your snack Supply with an
assortment of over 36 quick bites
smoothies juices and more satisfying
add-ons uh you can achieve and maintain
your goals this year with Factor get
America's number one right ready to
email kit and start saving time eating
well and living your best year ever our
producer John we never let him go home
he stays here all night and he eats
Factory meals and he loves it it's
delicious but lots of us here use
factors Tommy's gonna start Factor
February uh they have a nice keto
section and I've already end up buying
their keto yeah I love I love like
cooking dinner it's great it's a moment
for me to get away from everything from
this awful job and just focus on my
dinner uh but every now and then I don't
want to make dinner and I just pop in a
factor meal and I tell my wife I spend
hours cooking it and she doesn't know
any better head to factormeals.com break
room 60 and use code break room 60 to
get 60 off your first box can you
imagine saving that much on your first
box of factor meals that's called break
room 60 at factormeals.com break room 60
to get 60 off your first meal uh or off
your first box uh we have had some super
chats which acknowledge those real quick
uh thanks to our super trailers out
there match 143 and both Christian
unpronounceable pointing out you gotta
like the video you can Alex what are you
doing out there do it for your boss boss
and Greg don't do it for me don't do it
for Jessica certainly but like the video
for Voss and Greg please it's great to
have them oh you can also do it for
Jessica I try really hard they can't you
could do it for Jessica but don't do it
today I will like the video I'm gonna go
like it right now specifically for
Jessica's right there uh new master
pointing out in regards to your requests
about apple pie I think it's overrated
give me pumpkin or give me death get out
of here agreed American Greed apple pie
all the way also pies are better than
cakes let's settle that argument right
now folks
Eric does not know how to live
in a video
[Laughter]
uh Lewisberry saying hope to get Dwayne
Johnson a Shazam oh boy technically is I
would like a pivot I would like a pivot
that is true that powers uh uh and
samill bettenfield saying shout out to
the real Rejects and King votes yeah
Greg here from the real rejects also
Tommy Bechtel is sending in four
thousand dollars saying kiss my grits
Tommy save that money
1.5 million I said afterwards oh okay
that's great that's great uh well some
more questions about we have about
Shazam too uh mandatory fun questions
these are these are mandatory questions
this is mandatory fun what no we weren't
doing management it says mandatory
I want to show Greg the screen do we
have the mandatory
it's gone it's dead forever uh some of
the other questions we had Jessica you
kind of started bringing this up right
like is the destruction of the city that
oh no come on come on
oh no don't let this man in here you're
supposed to be a doctor nasty yeah
where's doctor you said you were getting
surgery
it was all a dream this is wild here is
that racist oh there it is now we're
having mandatory the painting that's I'm
almost unsettled that the ghost of Tommy
Bechtel said nothing and I just just
passed through here like uh uh Hamlet's
father so the destruction we see in this
trailer of the city okay Philadelphia is
this real okay because like Batman
versus Superman dawn of Justice uh told
us what a big deal it was to have all
this like collateral damage a dragon
pushed through a building I mean not
very kind of young Billy there uh how is
that all real is that going to be a part
of this movie or do you think that's
like a mirror Dimension type thing you
know it's interesting once we find out
if it's okay or not okay do you think
that's when we address that it's in the
same universe as Batman maybe I don't
know what's funny is this culture the
parts of the trailer straight up
reminding me of Batman versus really
yeah I mean at the very end when he's
flying with the Spears and he's like
killing a doomsday-like character he's
almost sacrificing himself yeah and I
wonder if the movie itself is gonna have
oh there's a camera here I wonder if the
movie itself is gonna ask the type of
commentary about the destruction in the
world and I think it would probably deal
with it I don't know where this Theory
came from is the destruction of the city
real I never even bothered a theorize it
I think it will I think the Stadium's
gone like I think the uh they could also
have just like which I don't know how
fast it is evacuated everyone in the
city immediately because they're
destroying they're ripping through those
buildings it's bowling on to the people
it's the speed of mercury well it looks
like in the trailer the Shazam family
looks like they're an established group
in Philadelphia and I'm wondering if
they'll do do something with the
citizens having issues with that um
yeah they're destroying Philadelphia
Shazam
it was night time these are Office
Buildings is anyone even in them oh I'm
sorry that the cleaning and maintenance
crew but there's I mean they go security
they're overworked obviously they got to
clean like 30 different floors they're
not on all 30 floors at the same time
wow wow also this is a universe where AI
has taken all those steps
before after they uh make that sphere
around the city and the only it looks
like the only person because shazam's
family are taken out it looks like that
in the trailer looks like uh the kids
were taken out and Shazam is stuck in
that sphere Shield so it could just be
him and that Dragon like that's isolated
a part of the city and the people are
awesome I think it was a Sunday no one's
working on a weekend I'm just saying
they flew the planes on a Tuesday oh my
gosh uh I'm leaving John I want to go
home you brought up the staff okay what
do we think the deal is with that staff
uh the daughters this is called the
transition
[Laughter]
is it like super powerful they seem mad
that like Shazam the Shazam we has their
the powers that are rightfully due to
them is it not the same staff that the
guy that gave Shazam his powers has
Shimon hauntzer yeah well who's awesome
what's the characters the wizard The
Wizard yeah
uh was it not the same staff yeah it
didn't look like it doesn't it is like
of an old like uh um
branchy looking one don't look to me for
the answer and it looks like it's a
dirty looking still
two hands on that it's a big old
get out of here what are we going to
address the staff at this company well
um do we know much I don't I personally
don't know much about the doctors of
Atlas do we know a lot about the doctor
well they are the daughters of a man
named Atlas
Alice is one of the six names in the
Shazam the stamina of Atlas maybe this
is the staff of stamina oh okay maybe I
don't know there's probably a specific
thing that it is and I don't know enough
about the Laura to tell you I've seen
this trailer a few times and when I was
watching it the impression I got is that
an older Shazam I don't know if it's the
wizard or if it's Black Adam is the one
who killed yes Atlas okay part of me is
wondering if there is some real emphasis
on this staff in some regard if the
staff was used to kill happens it feels
like you should just break the staff
right but he's using the stuff yeah he
needs his staff to kill her yeah to
fight or to fight the dragon so that's
why my mind's gonna because yeah
his suit like is turning gray because
like they're so powerful they're and
like it seems like he takes like his
Shazam Lee's powers back and puts them
all in him and he's like Shazam time yes
yes and he's like I'll take it on and
then he's like I don't want to do it I
mean I think it is just that wizard
staff like I think that's it which
completely changed your yeah
shoot down everyone it's just weird to
have a different staff two staffs in a
movie well maybe they just do maybe it's
just two different staff two staffs
three Atlas daughters uh what's the next
question the next question is what other
mythological creatures could we see in
this film right we see the dragon of
course uh we see a unicorn a Minotaur
and either a chimera or like a manticore
oh what a human centipede I agree you
pitched that for every movie no is this
in your dreams correct this is Monsters
Inc okay
hopefully they didn't give away like all
of they're cool creatures we're going to
see let's see a griffin a griffin would
be nice
Bracken oh a kraken would be fine I'll
just go to the Sea at one point
Philly's Coastal it's Coastal Coastal a
little bit of a crackhead come in were
these I did not see the Unicorn I need
to go rewatch this trailer one of the
his sisters was riding me so these
animals are brought in by the daughters
of Atlas maybe or is it something that
like well the dragon bring the dragon
and Shazam the wizard is like you gotta
use mythological creatures against them
and they bring in more they all look
like they're made of Earth yeah I was
like the dragon resembles the staff and
that's why I was like oh okay they're
brought in from this but I did not see
the Unicorn parts I mean uh well you
should all stay tuned because Whitney
Bay and landingham is working right now
on our trailer breakdown it's gonna be
really great it's gonna be coming out
tomorrow so yeah you gotta find all the
details for it cross promote yeah yeah
that's how you do it without having to
answer the questions
we'll finish it we got to keep her
working no food until you finish giving
away the secrets of new Rockstar they
gotta know what's the deal with this
staff someone's got to fix the stamps
uh are there so we talked about like the
the headless Superman we saw in the last
film uh do you think there's any DC
cameos we could see in this movie and
the precarious state that DC is in and
they've been cutting cameos we were
going to get from other movies
do you think there's any we're going to
see here now the first trailer for this
referenced a lot of other DC Justice
League characters
are there any more cameos to be had in
the deal there's so many cameos who
could appear I don't think it's going to
be any ones that we've seen before with
specific actors no no Gal Gadot
heard rumors for so long that she was in
it but I feel like they would cut it
yeah because as we know like there's no
plans for a current Wonder Woman 3 what
they were talking about is kind of off
the table now and they're much like they
said well we could see Henry Cavill
again we could see Gal Gadot again as
Wonder Woman but I don't know if I mean
why not give her this and like be like
at least because I think from from the
Studio's perspective it's confusing to
fans when you introduce characters
there's the implication that they're
gonna appear again after this so what
happened to Henry Cavill yeah sure
man he still got a movie Brandon he's
swimming out there I think he's the one
I think I think either Aquaman or I
think uh a flash character I don't know
about that but I think someone else is
associated with the flash like a you
know I don't know someone someone else
from his world maybe maybe a Michael
eating Cameo since he's gonna be part of
that because they still want people to
go see that this summer and they want
you know people to see the next Aquaman
movie later in the year so they people
from that world might care who could
show up but other than that I don't
think it's going to be any of the
trilogy how would you feel if they have
one Trinity how would you feel if they
do have Wonder Woman show up I'd be like
okay explain this Steve's gone I'd be
like awesome cool I like everybody
can we see
just in Philadelphia on vacation
on vacation no that's a hard day offer
doesn't take vacations no Alpha doesn't
take vacations no uh well it's possible
uh we did get a Super Chat uh from
Lewisberry saying hoping to get GLC with
with Reynolds and cars Lantern oh Green
Lantern core I mean
thorough Green Lantern in this movie why
not let's have a Green Lantern show up
in this movie yeah I wouldn't put Ryan
Reynolds though
so it's like screw it just do it
you see I think I think Green Lantern is
where James Gunn has the the most like
opportunity to just completely redefine
the core you know so like bringing a
completely new cast don't go back to the
past for that one especially Ryan
Reynold just moved on you know let's
just like completely introduce like make
people care about Green Lantern just
because I think a lot of people who who
aren't DC fans just think of it as a
joke but it is like the coolest part
yeah of DC Cosmic you know so like I
would love to see uh just a complete
fresh start with that what's who's the
guy from Top Gun who everyone wants to
be uh the new Hal Jordan the rooster
character Howell Glenn Powell Glenn
powers
I mean Glenn Howerton could be that
green lantern that makes the the
electric chair yes
I think Powell has Al Jordan and
Sterling K Brown is Jon Stewart okay
okay uh uh Daily Show Greg GSU Eagle
Center Super Chat They too had a dream
okay they had a dream about quantumania
but what if Kang was building a time
machine in his time but something went
wrong sending him and possibly the whole
city to the quantum Realm
it could happen I mean anything's
possible I love that theory so the
theory is that he's responsible for why
everyone's there in the quantum yeah
yeah he like sucked up a whole city from
the future and stuck him in I I really
think that's an entire city that is
there and I think that city is mobile I
think it's you know how like a season
five of lost ended with the entire
Island being unstuck from time I think
Kang did that with the city okay okay
okay
none of you watched lost shut up yeah
uh well no I'm not gonna lie I'm gonna
finish it now you don't need to I'll
just tell you everything that happens uh
I I love like the time machine analogy
uh because one of the my favorite things
about the story The Jules Verne version
of the time machine is like you build it
because he's trying to save his wife who
was like killed but he can never save
her because if he saves her he wouldn't
build a time machine it's like a very
cool Paradox that they set up with that
story uh and they I think they could
work here with like ravona rensslayer if
he's really after her and like he's kind
of stuck in a Time Loop trying to get
her I think that's what he's trying to
get with like using Scott Lang he needs
her to get
the youngest of the children I don't I
don't think this king will die I think
he I think they're setting him up to be
the big bad Kang right uh and we'll see
other kings later or there might be
multiple Kings in this I don't know I I
don't think Hank or Janet are dying but
I think they're staying in the quantum
realm for bad reasons
they're barely letting him because we
barely see him in the trailer yeah yeah
he finally got a line of dialogue in
that IMDb trailer they put out yesterday
where he's like I just saved eight bucks
I'd be surprised if this version of
Modoc survived because I think it's a
specific Modoc that's gonna be just for
this movie and it seems like a chance
for for Darren cross to have some
Redemption I think Secret Wars and Kang
Dynasty are going to reboot and recast a
lot of characters so we'll get a new
version of Modoc on the other side of
Secret Wars I think I'd be surprised if
they bring back Corey stole to be Modoc
for now on it's just such a specific
take on Modoc it's not the classic Modoc
we I mean we saw with Patton Oswald's
animated version there's like a lot of
fun to be had with that version of Moda
I mean modak is so ridiculous and fits
well in the quantum realm in the real
world I don't know
it's great it's great in the quantum
realm uh Tommy Bechtel standing in a
Super Chat do you think magic is real
and have you ever watched the sunset
that made you tear up a bit yeah I think
magic in our hearts and souls is real
but Practical Magic sorry no evidence of
it but I think the more powerful version
version of magic is the one that can
like change our hearts and make us love
each other when we did it before you've
never been to the Magic Castle oh I've
been there several times yeah I'm afraid
he's a member of the magic
I think there's really impressive
craftsmanship by people who are
magicians but they are magic but if they
are actually powerful why wouldn't they
be using it the way the characters and
now you see me do to Rob Base why aren't
they using it to loot Bagels
okay yes you may here's my problem with
now you see me this is now and now
you've seen the discussion
it's a movie about magicians using magic
to steal things and all the magic in
that movie is CG like just do real magic
why not there are real magicians doing
Illusions all the time Dave Franco
doesn't know how the entire real
magician well Jesse Eisenberg learned
some card tricks there's a real
douchebag about it in a interview
real magic
remember that you guys not know that
right yeah
okay and here I like how we're like yeah
she almost CG saves lives uh well I mean
that's like a big thing in like nope
right uh they have to use a CG
chimpanzee and nope
you couldn't use the real Predator alien
because they would actually want to kill
those horses based off the chimpanzee
that ripped the woman's face off that's
true so she's like yeah he's eating her
face sometimes space is delicious have
you ever had like I'm not answering this
question on on a recorded podcast oh boy
any more walk away thoughts about Shazam
too I mean you know
uh I asked that question uh but like
we're kind of you know we're really
waiting for James Gunn to kind of reveal
this slate it's supposed to happen this
month uh there's very few days left uh
they got this trailer out which makes me
think now they're ready to do the the
reveal right do you think we're gonna
see that reveal this week are they gonna
wait for next week I think I could ride
at the end of the month right at the end
honestly you know I feel kind of bad for
this movie I do too because it's getting
a lot of people a lot of the
conversations surrounding this film is
doesn't matter should we go see it and
I'm like yeah go see this movie they put
a lot of hard work into it they were
making this before the whole James gone
Peter saffron thing happened and I feel
like sometimes we are a little too
married to the idea of we need like us
like I like the idea of like a timeline
and everything continuing and all that
but at the same time sometimes it's good
to have just a nice stand-alone sequel
yeah the first movie really took a lot
of people by surprise I think and I I
really enjoyed it and like I said I
thought it was like one of the better DC
films that come out of you know the the
Snyder days of running DC yeah films and
it was great and it was like a very
refreshing so yeah certainly go see this
movie and not every movie has to be tied
into this giant Multiverse thing like
let them make good movies a lot of
people worked on it no one's trying to
make a bad movie here they were trying
to do their best and like respect this
character who's an old golden age
character which those are hard to do
right I think like our modern society I
think people need to remember that an
important and a critical step of every
story is that they come to an end and
we've been so reprogrammed by the
success of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
that no story ever ends any character
can get regenerated in a Multiverse or
can be respawned or Loki is playing a
trick on us and stories will never end
and then it has to set up some sequels
some crossover some tie-in film which is
super fun and it's been an interesting
experiment but it's the exception to the
rule the rule is good stories have to
end in order for them to have any impact
on us so I think James and again has an
opportunity here to make his Universe at
elseworld's universe that doesn't have
to tie in and interconnect so yes this
story matters if you can emotionally
connect to it yeah if it has an end hell
yeah it can matter it can matter more
than like your average MCU movie even so
they should restore the Snyder version
because that's what you're getting at oh
as I said what does think about I think
it's good for some things to come to an
end and one thing I loved about Zack
Snyder's Justice League is it seemed to
have a definitive ending I would even
say that epilogue of it I wasn't I
didn't need to see the the second part
of darkseid's invasion I was happy with
how that ended that epilogue made me
feel like we need more that's what I'm
saying oh well uh you know Eric uh
movies
need to end in Daily live shows from the
break room need to end folks uh thank
you so much for joining us today thank
you Jonathan pitcher for a very generous
superintendency on this post-credit team
yeah yeah there will be no post credit
scene to this episode of the break room
I'm so sorry we'll see about that we'll
see about that uh thank you Greg first
[Music]
I learned something new every day and
hey at 4 30 p.m Pacific time I'm gonna
be over on the real rejects with this
guy hopefully we can be set up by then
and we're gonna have like a one-on-one
interview I I have so many questions for
you about like your origin story so I'm
curious to Oh No One's Gonna want to
hear about me level theories in your DC
theories oh you got plenty of that a
sneak peek uh be back here live tomorrow
same time same network uh live from our
very own break room uh stay tuned on the
channel like we said Whitney's working
on a breakdown of that Shazam 2 trailer
and we have lots of other great content
coming out uh thank you so much for
joining us today we hope you have a
great rest of your Thursdays late as gay
as we'll catch you next time
[Music]
foreign